what was the strategy going into this
match what were you thinking were you
okay uh for Andre Galvan
he
there's a sense in which Andre gavon had
to fight literally the perfect match to
win this okay this this is a match it's
going to be 20 minutes long
um and potentially 40 minutes long
um
Andre gomon cannot win by submission
Gordon's submission
dominance here is is just too great
uh it would be exceedingly difficult for
him to win on the ground uh Gordon's
ground positional game is just too
advanced and so for Andre Galvan he had
to win if he was going to win it was
going to be in a standing wrestling
exchange where most people assist him as
having a measure of superiority over
Gordon Ryan
the problem is
that
it's hard
to just keep a potentially 40 minute
match on the ground sorry off the ground
that whole time it's it's very very
difficult indeed so he would have had to
fight literally the perfect tactical
match to make it happen and he would
have to do it without getting called
with stalling points
um
Gordon has the luxury that if at any
point they go to the ground he has
complete dominance but Gordon too has a
problem that he can't pull god without
being penalized and uh if Andre Galvan
can play this tactical game of forcing
Gordon to pull guard
and then staying at a distance where he
doesn't he's doing enough action not to
get called for stalling but not so much
to engage with the dangerous Gordon Ryan
on the ground then it's feasible he
could have won
but it would have been as I said it
would have required the most perfect
application and integration of technique
and tactics
that that he's capable of
intimidation was here
was there uh or are these assets already
beyond that uh when you say intimidation
be more precise
do you think there is some degree if
you're just to empathize with Andre
gaval do you think there's some degree
in which Gordon was in his head
um because of the Trash Talk leading up
to certain events because of the level
of dominance that Gordon has shown in
this competition and in the
uh months and years leading up to it
also the fact that Andre gaval is also a
coach of a large team so there's some
pressure to demonstrate to the team
that the old line still got it yeah
um I can't speak for Andre but uh I know
for Gordon
it's hard to be intimidated when you
know the other guy has no method of
finishing you
it's it just takes so much pressure off
when you just go in there saying this
there's literally no way this guy can
finish me
um
and there's no way this guy can pin and
control me
I can't be finished I can't be pinned
and controlled
the only way I can lose this
is if this guy plays a tactical game
so in his best case scenario
I lose my Tactical
by a tactical game but from Andre's
perspective was like if I make one screw
up this kid could finish me
like it's you can see which way the
intimidation game goes
now for the start things get interesting
here we've already said if you can just
freeze it right there
Andre's only real realistic part to
Victory is standing grappling okay that
would require him to take Gordon down
presumably multiple times after the
first 10 minutes and not be taken down
at all by Gordon so it's a tall order
it's possible but difficult
and here's where things get interesting
I told Gordon before the match
just go out and offer him the leg same
we did with Nikki rod
and that's where things get interesting
I must say that I loved what Andre
Galvan did at the start of this match
he's a little crazy here this is there
was just so much energy in the room at
this point that his hand finding God oh
for people just listening there's uh
there's a bit of hard slapping yeah that
could be considered a strike it's fine
it's um there was just a lot of electric
atmosphere in the room so now things
settle down a little bit
um but here's where things get
interesting Andre
throws the whole tactical game out the
window right from the start
he goes for the takedown Gordon doesn't
try to fight the takedown because it's
in his interests to go to the ground but
this I love this about Andre he's
literally like [ __ ] you kid
like let's see how good your ground game
is yeah so he shoots the takedown
um and Gordon accepts it obviously
because it's to his advantage to accept
it
but I love the fact that Andre was like
I'm not even going to try and stall this
out I'm just going to bang there it is
so he's like okay let's see what you got
kid they say you good on the ground
let's see what you [ __ ] got and I
love that about Andre
unfortunately he's entered the uh The
Hornet's Nest now what happened there
real quick because that was very
important immediately went into
ashigrami not just any ashigurami but
ashirami was holding both legs so it was
an open guard and he scooted forward oh
wow that's really nice so it's against
the legs now he dominates the space
between the knees so there's a
guaranteed straight out sugar Army here
he split the knees against Andre galvao
like effortlessly right there
wow
so already Gordon's in his preferred
domain now so he's starting to off
balance his opponent he's looking for
reaction to get heel exposure he does
get heel exposure Andre's uh does a good
job of monitoring the feet to try and
reduce the braking pressure but the The
Brute fact is it's in Gordon's realm now
this is this is where he has all the
advantage so um and the match is going
to be 20 minutes of in Gordon's realm
that's going to be a very very tall
order
foreign
was there a moment here
again Gordon's on the legs are you
impressed that Andre was able to get out
from this corner I would expect this and
Andre's been preparing for this for two
years and um uh he remember Andre has
gone against some of the greatest uh leg
Locus and grappling before and Prevail
so he's he's not naive you know he knows
how to defend himself
um the big problem is that he's going to
create defensive reactions which lead
into other aspects of Gordon's game in
particular back exposure so here uh
ashigrami goes to like a single leg type
of position where Gordon Runs to Andre's
back
now it has to return them to the mat the
most efficient way to do so is always
courtesy of foot sweeping so he pulls
out a DIY from the back to sweeten down
to the man
and now Gordon's on top and this
is a serious problem for any Grappler in
the world once Gordon gets top position
he's just relentless
but just getting Andre gavar's good just
getting the guard back all of that is
great there's also a sensor in which
Gordon is pacing it too just to
physically fatigue an opponent
foreign
but not rushing it
now what Gordon's looking for here is
complete chest to Chase contact
he's getting very close to it now
and once he gets chest to chased on an
opponent in top position past one of his
opponent's knees it's going to be
awfully awfully difficult for an
opponent to recover
what is he waiting for here is the this
pressure here over time he just wears
you out yeah it's part of a campaign of
attrition of pressure over time now he's
creating a situation where he's he's
either going to get back exposure or
Mount exposure and either way is pretty
much fatal when you're dealing with
Gordon Andre elected to to go the route
of back exposure
now Gordon got the body triangle is on
his back
and now it's uh now there's one physical
problem here that's uh Andre Galvan has
a neck like a bull and um he's a very
short and very thick neck so penetrating
under the chin for the strangle can be a
real problem he also has extremely well
developed shoulders and upper arms so
when the head comes down and the
shoulders go up there's very little real
estate to work with with regards to
strangle holds so Gordon in time will
trap one of his opponent's arms with his
legs in order to take away one of those
strong defensive arms there you can see
the arm has been trapped and now we can
see nobody towards the strangle
and now here is still difficult it's
still difficult but um things are
looking good there's still a
considerable amount of time left on the
clock Gordon as well ahead on points so
all the pressure all the Tactical
pressure now is on Andre
you'll see the critical penetration of
the jaw with the wrist there wow yeah
I'll go in the legs for a one-handed
strangle
me
wow Andre fought very bravely
but
a strangle it doesn't matter how Brave
you are and where where does the
strangle actually happen in terms of
um
it felt like the strangle was at the
blade of the it wasn't even fully sunk
in yeah so where does is that the full
Karma was like um one-handed there's a
sense in which once you get underneath
you know the inevitable yeah follow-up
is again the inevitable you're feeling
the inevitable it's like a um to go back
to your chest analogy it's like
resigning inches yeah and chess is
considered almost like impolite to let
let it run out when you understand yeah
when you understand that death is
on the horizon
and there's a lot of
there's a lot of respect that was the
beautiful thing with all the trash talk
and everything like that Gordon always
shows respect I love that
um about the drama of combat
is trash talk in the beginning and
respect at the end I think it's you know
when you when you feel someone uh Andre
has great skills and uh when you when
you grapple someone you feel just how
skilled they are and um uh it whatever
issues you had prior to the match
evaporate when you when you feel that
okay they're just like you they do the
same moves and same kind of Concepts and
and you see that there's more that bonds
you together and separates you and uh
that's the feeling that the end of most
grappling matches